while you're doing Mission Unstoppable
what's the coolest science fact that you
found from the show um well I've
experienced sleep paralysis before I
don't know if what has ever happened to
you guys um it's where you wake up your
eyes are open and you're lying in bed
but you're asleep so your dreams that
you're having seem like they're
happening in the room you're in like
your eyes are open but you can't move
that that's terrifying have you ever
experienced that or do you I've
experienced something similar but I'm
not sure if it's quite the same but yeah
there's something what's similar like
insomnia well I'm not quite sure but it
seems like uh yeah I was at sleep
briefly but I was wide awake uh My Eyes
Are Open I'm Yelling to the Sky I'm
completely paralyzed in the bed and
can't move and no I think that's kind of
exactly like what she just said exactly
yeah it sounds terrifying yeah yeah it's
so scary and we did this whole segment
on it and it was crazy they're talking
about how the best thing you can do is
have a really set sleep schedule and try
to really stick to it because it usually
happens when you're stressed or really
tired oh my God that's it's like the
most annoying thing a doctor can tell me
are you stressed and I'm like am I
breathing I'm like there's a lot on the
plate I'm like yeah there's no button
for it but okay but I've never
experienced that so maybe I'm doing all
right yeah I think yeah I'm good because
if I were yeah I think that would I
think yeah God knows I can't handle that
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody